it seems like it that's what i'm hearing
uh this morning
ian trying to get some more details
about exactly what that extra cash
is uh but the the words from my source
at lancaster county council saying
that we won significant successions and
additional cash from government uh i
think liverpool will be looking
here and saying okay well where's our
extra money and i think the talks with
greater manchester will probably
continue
to find out whether they are going to
get extra money to get
into tier 3 restrictions but i think the
important news here
is that lancashire will be heading into
tier 3
lockdown restrictions which will be the
most severe lockdown restrictions we
currently have
in this country only the liverpool city
region currently
in those restrictions and that means
that bars and pubs will
have to shut provided that they
predominantly don't serve food
and there will also be closures of
casinos
gyms as well and betting shops so a real
hit to the hospitality
sector in lancashire but it comes with
potentially
more money is what uh i am hearing this
morning uh just getting uh some details
uh about exactly how
lancashire will be impacted by this uh
ian we know
that around 1140
pubs and bars will shut in lancashire
blackpool and
and blackburn with darwin uh there will
be around
98 gyms that will shut
and betting shops uh as well will
completely close and three casinos
uh so obviously a lot of businesses
impacted
by tier three restrictions and the fact
now
that we know lancashire will be heading
into tier three lockdown restrictions
with some extra cash but what that extra
cash is
we are still unsure so we're finding
that out we'll let you know as soon as
we hear something
but this really is now a major step for
the north of england and whether greater
manchester follow suit and whether
the government gives that extra cash to
them as well for them to head out
in tier three we know there's that
bitter row between the leaders of
greater manchester
and the government whether that happens
today is something we'll have to keep
an eye out for but we are expecting more
detailed announcement of this particular
move
of lancashire heading into tier three
later today